okay great let's get started so welcome
everyone to the fireside chat or talk on
ai and language
um so today we're going to do something
a little bit different i want all of you
good to go to slide
oh
and
the guest code is cs221 so we're going
to try to use this
platform for doing q a and also i'm
going to have a number of polls
throughout
the talk
so the first question if you click here
you'll hopefully see that it's what city
are you in right now
and i already got some responses san
jose palo alto stanford
seattle um
college station
fort mill
cupertino new york city
so welcome everyone from all over
um and if you go oops i guess
this
zoom thing is in a way okay i guess i
can't
see that but
anyway you can go to there should be a q
a tab
um
where you can go and type in your
questionnaire uh try to monitor that
throughout the
hour
okay
um all right so
i wanna start by asking you a very
simple question what is the difference
between these two cute little kittens
and these two kids here
anyone know the answer
both can see smell
taste move around the environment
kids are sometimes cute too
what's the what's the main difference
let's make this interactive someone just
just shout out an answer
humans can talk
humans can talk yes thank you
that is the main difference and while
animals do have
some sorts of communication especially
songbirds and dolphins and and honeybees
have their waggle dance
none i think could boast as such a rich
and complex language as the human
language so it's really i think language
is something that's uniquely human and
defines who we are
so before getting into
talking about ai and nlp i want to talk
spend some time just talking about why
language is special and hopeless that we
can get a richer appreciation for a
language
so if i had one slide to summarize
language um this would be it
so this is one of my favorite xkcd
comics um some of you probably seen it
but i'll just read it anyway because i
think it really highlights the the right
mode so
anyway i could care less
i think you mean you couldn't care less
saying that you could care less implies
that you care at least some amount
i don't know
we're these unbelievably complex brains
drifting in the void trying to in vain
to connect with one another by flinging
uh words out into the darkness every
choice of phrasing and spelling and tone
timing carries countless signals and
context and subtext and more and every
listener interprets these signals in
their own way language isn't a formal
system it's glorified chaos
and you never know for sure what any
words will mean to anyone all you can do
is try to get better at guessing how
your words affect people so that you
have a better chance of finding ones
that will make them feel something like
what you want them to feel everything
else is pointless
so i assume you're giving me tips on how
you interpret words because you want me
to feel less alone if so
then thank you that means a lot
but if you're just running my sentences
past the mental checklist so you can
show off how well you know it then i
could care less
so
what do we learn from this so first
language
is is social it's it's meant for
communication right i think a lot of us
coming more from a kind of data or ml
background i think language is just a
body of text but it's really this uh
this dynamic thing that humans invented
communicate with each other
the other thing is that language
or talk is is cheap
um and something about language requires
incredible amount of trust between the
people so that
it actually can can function but
interestingly it can also be used to
deceive which is
interesting right now
and it's just kind of miraculous how
language allows us to express all these
different thoughts from poetry to math
to
how to fix a bike and so on
so where did language come from the
short answer is no one really knows and
it's really hard to pinpoint it because
while writing came around 3000 bc and
before then it was a long period of
spoken language and spoken language
doesn't leave fossils or anything
um and there was so much skeptic
kind of controversy around that that was
actually banned the study of origins of
language was banned for about a hundred
years and
um
in paris
so but but we do
just kind of conservatively put an
estimate it started maybe
2.5 million years ago when homo sapiens
first came on the scene to
sometime between 100 000 years ago which
is when modern humans really started
doing things
which is a huge range but to put in
perspective this is a very recent
development compared to the history of
all of life on earth
um and
we know that it served an evolutionary
purpose so if you read sapiens this book
by yuval harari
language is perhaps one of the key
reasons why homo sapiens became so
dominant because they allowed you to
communicate and coordinate on such
massive levels and for example detecting
when coordinating on the hunt for
example or
communicating about food sources and so
on um and interesting language allows
you to talk about things that aren't
here and now
that that is probably the one of the
most powerful things and in fact it
tells allows you to talk about things
that don't even exist there's a whole
genre called fiction that's about that
and things which are in the abstract
so
um in contrast like i said before you
know our kind of uh
sister fields of
you know computer vision robots uh
robotics uh tap into capabilities that
have been around for you know much much
longer like vision is over 500 million
years ago and language is you know
barely let's say
uh conservatively maybe of a million or
two years ago
so uh just for fun let me do a poll um
let me actually have to create the poll
first so what language do you speak
languages do you use
here speak
let's see multiple choice free text
okay
let's see if this works
i have to disable
okay so go to the poll and
let you fill that out
so
we know that
language there's not one language
there's multiple languages
and furthermore languages
have
evolved
so you can draw kind of a giant family
tree of languages
and this branch just shows the
indo-european languages which covers all
of europe and iran and some parts of
northern india which developed like 10
000 years ago and this branch often to
kind of germanic languages and romance
languages germanic went into german and
english and so on and today there's um 6
500 languages
many of which are actually going extinct
because language again is social so if
you don't have anyone to talk to your
language just kind of disappears
and language is changing all the time
you know english has definitely evolved
since shakespeare
but you know i think in grade school
you're probably told that they is
supposed to be plural and you shouldn't
use say they to refer to a singular
person but now it's uh
especially with kind of this trend for
um
having gender neutral pronouns they is
you know kind of proudly singular and
miriam webster kind of declared it as
the word of the year in 2019
um you can think about internet slang
and emojis is also kind of a
continuation of language into the kind
of digital sphere and so on
um
okay so i'm getting a lot of english
mandarin chinese
japanese
so you know quite a bit of uh
python 2 python 3. yes very nice
okay so
one thing that is
i often get asked is you know all these
languages are some more harder or more
powerful than another um it's clear that
they're and i think widely accepted that
all languages are kind of basically
equivalent but there is kind of this
hypothesis around the 20s called the
superior wharf hypothesis that says the
structure of language affects speaker's
world views
and you see this in kind of a fiction
like george orwell's 1984 which talks
about a new language called newspeak
which was simplified so that they could
make sure people couldn't think to even
critique their government
um this has been challenged by a
universalist school chomsky and pinker
who thinks that language and thoughts
are universal and all the differences
are very superficial governed by a few
parameters
and
it is true that languages do differ
they are largely the same most languages
have nouns and verbs that refer we all
are humans living in the in the same
world um but there are some differences
you know one for an example is that
english lacks what is called uh
inclusivity which is the distinction
between
when you say we it's ambiguous whether
you mean
to include the speaker or not to include
the speaker whereas some languages like
tamil
or some chinese dialects actually have
that distinction
or mandarin chinese lacks the
distinction between past tense and
present tense but of course has other
ways of you know accommodating for that
um
so one question uh maybe to just have
another poll is
let me stop that poll is do you believe
believe that language shapes thought
now
i know that these uh questions are
um you know obviously not binary but i
just wanted you to kind of you know get
a gut feeling are you leaning more
towards yes or no on that and i will
activate that
poll so if you are do you kind of abide
more by the uh superior warf hypothesis
that the structure of language does
influence how you think about the world
or do you think that uh all humans are
really the same and as we just happen to
learn different languages and those
differences are fairly minor
so can you guys see the
um
the numbers
okay so we have
about 90 percent superior dwarf um
and about 10 no okay
so uh this is a richly hot hotly debated
topic in linguistics even you know to
this day
so another fascinating thing about
language is
that we're not born knowing it babies
can make sounds but it takes them a few
years to be able to actually acquire
language and importantly despite what
their parents might think they're
they're not taught from explicit
instructions
or from teachers rather they're taught
where they learn naturally from
immersion of language and you know by
the time they're five they're actually
fairly kind of have a fluent
grasp of the language and speak
grammatical sentences and so on um and
its language acquisition is very
multi-modal and grounded so language
accompanies sight and sounds and
actions and touch and all these things
and it's active you can't teach a child
by just putting in front of a tv and
expecting language acquisition to
um occur
so uh you know one of the big big
questions around language acquisition is
um
is is the nature of nurture debate which
also
affects kind of other
areas as well so
the great question is language
you know innate um and
um so chomsky who was a famous linguist
in the 50s he came up with this idea of
what he called poverty of the stimulus
and he said that
basically
sentences that a child hears can't
possibly
be
be responsible for the uh the richness
of language that's um you know exhibited
in actual
in actual humans
um
so
so he thought he concluded naturally
that language must be
a large part of language must be
innate
so i'm trying to delete this poll and
add it add a new one at the same time
i'm talking
okay so i'll ask you this poll um do you
think language is an egg
um
and if you think about it he does have
a fair
you know point because um
you know uh
you know we do as children here's so few
of the examples
and then we can uh
you know not nearly enough to really
capture all the cases and we are
constantly run into new language all
over the
all the time and we have to generalize
compositionally to longer sentences to
new context and we kind of all land on
this kind of same language so
um you know i think he
does have a point on the other hand you
know he was an experimentalist he was a
kind of a you know classic armchair uh
linguist who thought deep thoughts about
uh how things should be
um
and there's also you know one could
imagine you know what about the role of
grounding and maybe that is the it's
part of the experience that really
shapes
language
acquisition and maybe we are just kind
of really malleable and so on
so it seems like um everyone's quite
divided on this so 53 yes and 47
no
okay that's always fun so maybe you guys
can
you know talk about it that's with your
friends
um what i will say oh now now that whoa
this is a tight race
um what i will say is that you know no
matter where you're on the spectrum once
you have kids you you really think that
there's more innateness than there's not
so
now it's equal 50 50.
okay
great
so let's move on
so let's take a look at language you
know itself and i'm going to introduce
some basic concepts so there's a whole
field of linguistics that studies
language and i really encourage you if
you're interested to take a linguistic
class i think it's one of the most
interesting um eye-opening kind of
experiences um
but i'll just go over some kind of basic
things quickly so here's a sentence
beethoven was born in bonn and displays
his musical talents at an early age now
what's going on in the sentence the
linguists ask you know what is the
structure of the sentence allows us to
understand what it means so first of all
there's tokenization which is you know
the
uh the sentence is just a stream of
characters right and tokenization is a
process of converting that into words
seems very simple right but as we'll see
later it's not as simple as it kind of
looks um
uh part of speech tagging is uh the idea
that some words are nouns and other
words are
verbs and some of the words words verbs
are past tense versus present tense um
parsing goes a bit a step further and
talks about the grammatical relationship
between words for example displayed
has a subject and object and the subject
is in this case
what is the subject
anyone
i know they're english speakers in the
audience
is it bond
okay i think maybe it's okay it's
beethoven right okay so
um even though beethoven is very far
away from display it's nonetheless
grammatically very close to displayed
and this is what
this is a property of language language
has to be linearized so not everything
can be close to each other
um
core reference resolution or anaphora
corresponds to the fact that his some
words are
pointers to other words or concepts so
his refers to beethoven um named entity
recognition is the task of identifying
which entities now usually proper nouns
are per people or locations or
organizations
um
so
what is what is a word
so let's go down into a word so okay
here's a word light so
you know it seems like a word is pretty
straightforward forward at least in
english
but
the problem is that the meaning
of unit
what what is kind of conceptually should
be a word actually goes beyond a word so
light bulb is kind of a unit it's not um
light doesn't really capture the the
really the full meaning of that word um
sometimes the meaning unit is within a
word for example lightning isn't just a
blob it consists of light and then
the suffix en ing which kind of uh
you know trims it into
um a verb you know gerund construction
um there's also cases where words have
multiple meanings usually called word
senses so in all of these sentences you
can see that light actually has a
different meaning
and we figure it out based on context
on the converse
conversely
some
meanings have multiple words that refer
to essentially the same meaning that's
synonymy this also happens with
sentences so this is called paraphrase
multiple sentences could get at the same
meaning
just some huge caveat is that there's no
true equivalences between
any two words or sentence sentences
there's always different subtleties and
meanings so you can think of more as a
kind of distance metric
um there's also
notions of relations between words like
hypotonomy which is is a relations and
mironomy which is hazard relations and
this allows you to make do entailment um
which is whether a sentence um
logically um
implies a second sentence um entailment
you can kind of think about the the
three set of end of language it's kind
of the problem that embodies um a lot of
different tasks if you could solve
entailment you can do question answering
you can do sentiment classification you
know and so on
um
oh are there
i haven't been monitoring the qa i don't
know i don't think there's any questions
if you have a question maybe just uh
holler
so this is all about lexical semantics
the meaning of words um then we talk
about compositional semantics
um so this composition of semantics is
kind of rich tradition that goes back to
kind of logic so this is fraga who's a
was a logician at the turn of the 20th
century
and there's two ideas um model theory
and compositionality which i'll explain
so the first is that sentences
are these are just symbols right it's
it's a convention that we say block 2 is
blue and what
this sentence means has to be associated
with what is in the world so there's a
world in which the block 2 is actually
blue and so this is kind of important
distinction which we kind of you know we
kind of gloss over or you probably just
we don't even think of it because
of uh you know language is so
natural
the second one is compositionality which
is that the meaning of a whole is the
meaning of the parts so you could that
is this is compositionality is the key
thing that allows
us to build
more complex meanings out of smaller
units and this is probably the reason
why we can generalize to all sorts of
new contexts because we've learned
the meaning of the words and we know how
they combine
together and that's how we can generate
you know uh
we can interpret the new sentences and
new contexts
um
quantifiers i think are really you know
interesting so uh every is a word that
says uh
you know says that well it's hard to
explain language without explaining in
terms of language so every means every
hopefully these pictures tell you uh
what's going on and some is a kind of an
existential quantifier
there's also a quantifier scope
ambiguity which uh
means that if you have every non-blue
block is next to some blue block that
could mean that every blue block is next
to some blue block which is that that
was very tautological which is
is could be different or that there
exists some blue block that's actually
next to some
to every non-blue block
um
so language is you know ambiguous um
so modality uh
or involve words like must and can
um
and this
has to has to do with possible you know
worlds in all these possible worlds
block 2 is blue but block one is only
a true in is read in one of the worlds
um beliefs are
interesting so um
you know we know that clark kent is the
same person as superman
but
um and naively you might think that we
can just substitute these two
uh in all contexts because they're
equivalent but you know lewis believes
that
superman is a hero is not the same as
lewis believes that clark kent is a hero
and this has to do with the fact that
you know this believes sets up a kind of
opaque context which you can't just do
substitution
there's much more to be said you know
about this if you study linguistics i
just want to give you a flavor for
how language can be kind of quite subtle
um here's some other examples of you
know pragmatics
so um pragmatics the conversational
implicature is this phenomenon where um
there is a sentence that you say
um but there's actually additional
meaning beyond that sentence so if two
people are talking and
a says what earth happened to the roast
beef and b says the dog is looking very
happy
sure the dog is looking very happy
that's a sentence but really the
implicature is the dog ate the roast
beef
um presupposition is
is actually kind of very
you know
subtle but different is the background
assumption that's independent of the
truth of a sentence so if i say i have
stopped eating meat
what's the presupposition
that means i was once eating meat
okay so regardless of whether i have
stopped me or meat or if i even have i
said i didn't stop eating meat that
still pre-supposes i was once eating
meat so presuppositions are these very
slippery and insidious things that um
people
use
to convey um to convince other people of
things that without them knowing
so be it's really useful to know what a
presupposition is because if someone
tries to presuppose something on you
then at least you'll have the language
to you know detect what it is and it's
precisely insidious because it's in the
background so you're focusing on you
know uh did i stop eating meat without
realizing that you just got you know a
presupposition that you might not agree
with uh late on you
okay so um paul grice who's this full of
you know philosopher
um
the established uh with kind of
established language as a kind of
cooperative game between a speaker and a
listener and is that the dynamics of the
game is what gives rise to these things
like conversational implicature and
presupposition right this goes back to
xt comment it's really a
a game between speakers and listeners
who are trying to communicate and agree
on something and the conventions and
what language means in all these
contexts is uh really kind of context
dependent and fluid
uh just a few other ideas um ambiguity
vagueness and uncertainty so let me try
to
explain what each of these means and how
it's different so ambiguity means that a
sentence has more than one
possible but precise interpretation so
here are some headlines um and let me
know what you think of them
okay so stolen painting found by tree
okay so what does that mean
how about iraqi head seeks arms
or local high school dropouts cut in
half
juvenile court to try shooting defendant
kids mix nutritious snacks ban on new
dancing on governor's desk
and you can see if you're i have smiling
a little bit that um
these these
headlines are funny because they have uh
a
maybe a serious meaning and then a
meaning which is totally ridiculous but
um is nonetheless
kind of technically ambiguous
um vagueness
is where a sentence is not uh
has one interpretation but it does not
specify the full information so if i
said i had a late lunch
you know there's no
ambiguity there it's just that i didn't
tell you what time i laid lunch maybe it
was one o'clock or two o'clock or
something
uncertainty is another form of you know
not knowing something and it's due to
having a perfect uh model
so say the witness was being
contumacious um
you know some of you probably know what
that means so you're not uncertain but
you know i'm some of you probably don't
um
and uh you have this uncertainty which
is not a property of the sentence
but of your uh the speaker's ability to
understand you know natural language
so all these things are
useful to think about differently
although often they get conflated
especially in kind of more
model-free
methods
um so i will say that there is another
forum of style of linguistics called
distributional semantics which is
actually goes back to the 50s as well um
and i'll give you the basic idea so if i
give you these sentences the new design
has blank lines
let's try to keep the kitchen blank
i forgot to
blink out the cabinet
so what does blank mean
or which what word goes there
someone say the answer
the answer's a chat
oh okay i didn't know there was a this
is in the zoom chat
yep okay
let's see
uh
i think i lost
my
[Music]
okay chat okay there we go
ah okay there are our answers okay clean
great
okay got it
okay so the idea about disreputation of
semantics is i didn't have to tell you
what the word means the meaning of the
word is characterized by the contexts in
which it appears so this is idea of the
distributional hypothesis semantically
similar words occur in similar contexts
or more eloquently said by
firth you shall know a word by the
company it keeps
so this is another way of thinking about
semantics um
and actually the one that has
really been uh
picked up because it's so synergistic
with a modern kind of statistical
techniques
so just going to summarize um
there's there's two ways of thinking
about semantics or meaning of sentences
one is composite essential semantics
where it's more top down and you model
first so you think about how
language works you try to you know think
about parse trees or you know semantic
forms
um and you can capture a lot that way we
can we went through a lot of examples
where
language you can feel kind of language
does obey certain types of structures on
the other hand you can
think about distribution of semantics
which is a bottom-up data first approach
and generally associated with vector
spaces where
you think about just words as
meaning and not really trying to nail
down what meaning is but just associated
with the set of contexts in which you
know appears
so let me do another
poll
and
let me hold on i need to create this
question
um
and ask
what do you think is the best way to
achieve natural language you know
understanding
so is it compositional semantics or
distributional semantics
okay so go to slido and
i'm curious what you you think
okay so
it would have been interesting to go
back maybe 10 years and ask this
question
because i think the answers would have
been quite different
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that in a bit
so it looks like
it's about 30
compositional and 70
maybe quarter three quarters
so most of you think that distributional
semantics is the way to go
which is uh
maybe a concordant with
what is happening in the world right now
okay so why do i take um
a few minutes right now i went through a
lot of material and maybe i'll just ask
if there are any questions
to discuss
no questions
someone has to have a question
so one question is context information
it's never spelled out but the meaning
depends on who is speaking out where
yeah so i've been kind of deliberately
vague about what context
is
um traditionally it's a linguistic
context which is the words next to a
sentence but um you could imagine that
it could be very much generalized to
uh
you know context of
the speaker
in the you know multilink multimodal
what's going on in the world what who is
speaking to whom the person is speaking
and all of that
rich
you know contextual information
it definitely is uh
useful for understanding the meaning of
that word
um so in the beginning you said that
humans have the highest level of
communication how likely is it that so
actually some animal has much higher
level of communication but we're not
smart enough to understand it yeah
that's a that's an interesting question
um
so
um
it's yeah it's almost a little bit of a
you know philosophical question
uh because
um
you know it is you know in theory
possible that some animal has you know
brilliant system of communication and uh
we just didn't you know measure it you
know properly people have been surprised
by how sophisticated certain animals are
able to you know communicate um
you know like you know dolphins or
elephants or even you know uh um you
know bees
often people
separate the line between having
recursion or
language that's able to express kind of
compositional thoughts versus ones which
are maybe very contextual
nuanced but um
but don't have that kind of level of
abstraction
um
and so
you know according to that i think we're
pretty sure that humans are
the ones that have the most amount of
abstraction but then again i guess this
is also a very human-centric way of
defining you know what highest level of
communication means um because maybe
some other creatures have more you know
contextual more nuanced than you in
human language
um
elephants communicating below 20 hertz
infrasound
um
okay and hitchhiker guide thanks
that's a good one how about uh plants
communication can be
um
chemical color temperature even touch
yeah so there's a lot of other and i
guess in general communication is not
the
uh
you know same thing as as language
yeah so i'm using language very narrowly
here to mean kind of human language and
what we know to be human language of
course even humans communicate in other
ways like gestures and
um
and so on
okay great let me move on um
for the questions
so what i want to do next is to talk
about
building language understanding systems
and what has happened over the last
60 years
now that we have maybe a greater
appreciation of what
language is
um
so we've kind of seen this slide before
it's the turing test alan turing in 1950
asked the philosophical question devise
the terrain test
to
test whether
um
you know a a
computer could be or a machine could be
intelligent by
seeing if it could talk to a human and
convince the human that it was actually
a person
um this is one of the dialogues that
they have in from his paper
um you can read it
um what i want to emphasize here is that
you know turning was not interested in
language
and wasn't trying to design a language
understanding test he was trying to
design
a test of intelligence
and language was just
the means to convince someone or to kind
of verify that there was something you
know up there
um
and so i think this is kind of very
interesting from an ai perspective
because language does seem like it has a
unique capability of
being able to
even
you know
in order to have intelligence you need
to be able to
uh
essentially
show it in some way and um
and you can think all the deep thoughts
in your head but if you don't have a way
of kind of externalizing it then well
it's it's like the if the tree falls in
the
forest doesn't make a sound kind of you
know setting
um so and it
language has turned out to be a very uh
useful way of kind of probing for
understanding
one of the early systems i want to
highlight
is
know eliza so joseph weisenbaum when he
was at mit
um developed this system
called elisa which was really meant to
be a parody of a psychotherapist
so the system
would uh you would lie on a couch and
you would talk to the system
um and uh some dialogues would go like
this or eliza would say is something
troubling you men are all like what's
the connection do you suppose they're
always bugging me about something or
other can you think of a specific
example well my boyfriend made me to
come here
is it important to you that your
boyfriend made it you come here this is
so depressed and so on
um so
what was interesting about this system
is that
the system itself is very simple this is
you know 1960s so there's not that much
kind of
you know going on in terms of you know
complexity it was based on rules and
matching so you can imagine a rule that
says if the word alike shows then you
ask you know what is the connection or
if you
uh say always
then you say can you elijah says can you
think of an example specific example and
so on
um so it was very simple but what joseph
weisenbaum found out which was
really surprising is that the people he
uh showed this to actually started
getting emotionally attached and there
was one incident where as invalid
secretary actually asked joseph to leave
the room so that the secretary could
have a you know a real conversation with
eliza
so
this is kind of in the 60s i think it
was very perhaps
you know i guess telling of maybe what
is to come later i'll talk about gpg3
which is obviously a much more realistic
version of this but you could think
definitely about some of the you know
consequences of of that technology
incidentally
weisenbaum later
in his career became very pessimistic
and actually very negative and critical
about you know technology maybe because
he uh had this epiphany that well what
we're building is actually maybe not so
good after all
um so this is one of my kind of favorite
natural language uh you know systems
it's been built by terry buenograd
was also at mit but he moved to stanford
where he was became a you know a hdi
faculty for a number of years um it's
called churlu and the idea is that you
have a person who is able to conduct a
dialogue about a block's world
environment so pick up a red block okay
grasp the pyramid this computer is going
to say when it doesn't understand things
um
you know find a block which is taller
than when you're holding and put it into
the box so it's you know fairly
complicated and that the computer can
kind of reason and do a nap for a
co-reference resolution um
and ask for clarifications and so on
um what i think is remarkable
about the system
is that it was an end-to-end system um
included a parser it can do semantic
interpretation dialogue planning it
wasn't just a language system in fact it
was more framed as an ai system that
could allow
a robot to kind of do things in the
world
um you know
and so this was you know in some sense
um kind of the first the real super
ambitious uh project for its time
however um you know while sherloo worked
really well in the limited domain
um terry werner later wrote this
paragraph which is interesting said a
number of people suggest me that
this is a dead end in programming
complex interactions between the
components
made it just really hard to
understand what was going on
so eventually
terry couldn't even
build and extend the program because it
was just too hard to keep you know in
his head
so this is you know interesting because
uh as we know um language understanding
didn't you know really get uh
you know solved despite these kind of
narrow successes
um
and
the history of nlp
mirrors uh quite closely the history of
you know ai
in general remember in the first lecture
i talked about how um ai was filled with
more kind of these logical based methods
which
didn't quite scale
what's interesting is that at that
at that time in ai in general there were
people
working on neural networks although the
vast minority of people but in language
it was perhaps even less so because i
think language is actually
a discrete communication system
and linguist
there was kind of a rich body of work on
linguistics and nlp and linguistics kind
of um you know uh co-evolved in
in certain ways that made it kind of
um very natural to embrace the kind of
all the the logical structure that was
embodied in you know in language
um
but you know i think people realize that
the there was cracks that were you know
showing at the seams in the even in the
70s but especially the late 80s and
in 1990 it was a time for
a new set of methods to come onto the
scene
um so this actually started
uh a bit earlier from speech recognition
because speeches and language are you
know closely related and speech is
definitely something that you know uh is
the bridge between the continuous
kind of noisy world where you want to be
doing kind of more pattern recognition
type things and the kind of a logical
world
um so hmms uh hidden marker models were
developed for speech in the 70s and 80s
and
finally in 1990 there was a kind of
famous paper from ibm research um
colloquially called the ibm models for
machine translation they developed a
probabilistic model that could translate
between um you know two languages and at
before then um translation was
completely kind of logical and grammar
and rule based and this was a radical
way of thinking about it this is
actually instantly based on a lot of the
bayesian networks or that we'll see you
later in the course
um so for a lot of the 90s a lot of
these uh what are called generative
models um think about them extensions of
asian networks really kind of dominated
uh nlp
um near about 2000 um
there were uh people started turning to
discriminative models
um you know aka uh you know
classification linear classification um
and um there was another famous paper
called which introduced conditional
random fields which uh marries the
structure that was so inherent in in
language with
um
with
basically linear classification
uh so this was used to do things such as
named entity recognition where you would
mark up words as
names of people or companies and so on
and so instead of predicting just one y
from x you predict a bunch of y's
from x where y's are the labels of all
the words
um so this technology was actually quite
influential in
in nlp but also more broadly in computer
vision
where for much of the
2000s people were invested in having
this was a kind of main way people
tackle kind of structured tasks
another thing i'll mention is lane
dirichlet allocation which also
uh came from models of language and here
the emphasis on unsupervised learning
where you point lda at a text and it can
discover topics
in the text so here's a text where it
can discover things like oh some words
are about budget some words about
children and some words about arts in
kind of unsupervised way and this led to
a whole
kind of cottage industry of topic
paper topic modeling papers and lda you
know continues to be something that
you know is commonly used in you know in
practice
what i will say is that a lot of
these developments
it's interesting to kind of think about
how they were developed by someone
trying to solve
address a problem in natural language
processing and it led to of more general
technology that then was applied in all
sorts of different you know areas like
computer vision and genomics and so on
okay so so now um 2000 uh you know we're
ending
and we know that
at the end of the 2000s deep learning
really started gaining momentum
it wasn't you know it was imagenet was
2009 so it wasn't like a
you know a huge yet but there was
definitely kind of rumblings um and it's
interesting how kind of culturally how
the nlp community kind of reacted
at the time nlp and vision were both all
very kind of skeptical and if you think
about where nlp had been a lot of people
still view languages you know structure
heavy and languages has a lot of lane
structure and no way that this mess of
neurons could actually do anything uh
with this kind of
intricate structure um and you can think
about a lot of the work in
the 2000s was really a marrying of this
structure with kind of statistical
methods
um so it was you can think about as
putting probabilistic
choices on kind of this very rich uh
structure discrete backbone right so in
some ways this is kind of a
reconciliation of the compositional
semantics with the distribution of
status you have it you have both um
but but still i think
it was still
largely based on kind of traditional
kind of linguistic thinking so then um i
remember there was this
2011 you know workshop at nureps um
i was at it um and there was uh
there were some
uh so neurops is you know the machine
learning conference so there were a
bunch of machine learning people who
were using vector based models to argue
that this covers semantics and then you
have ray mooney who is much more of a
logic old-school ai
at the time kind of person
and a heated argument kind of broke out
and he is famous for saying you know you
can't cram the meaning of a whole
sentence into a single uh vector
um
okay so so that was captured the
attitude you know at the time
um
and then things kind of started changing
i think the first kind of um
you know maybe move was uh you know word
to vec which was this way of taking a
lots of text and
embedding words
so that each embedding was uh
characterizing the context of that word
so actually word representations have
been had been around you know since the
90s but it was somehow this word event
uh
was came at the right time that
really caused people to pay attention
and i think one thing that they noticed
which
gathered a lot of attention was
the fact that you could do analogies for
example if you embed things in a vector
space you see that country and capitals
are related by a consistent you know
relationship you know with some
asterisks
there was a recent paper from last year
which i'll
which i'll just highlight because i
thought it was really interesting i mean
six years later and they used a kind of
a simplest method but it was um they ran
this uh word event just on you know
about
three million abstracts of material
science papers um just strings and they
were able to discover certain types of
patterns um by looking at the vector
spaces and actually predict uh certain
types of chem
compounds as being having certain kind
of material properties like you know
therm being thermoelectric
so uh this is kind of an interesting
uh
view of how something that's so
kind of you know dead simple and knows
nothing about chemistry and only knows
about what crew occurrences can actually
you know generate some interesting you
know insights
um so word effect wasn't
um you know deep learning in the sense
that it was only i guess one layer so it
was kind of shallow learning
and i think
uh
2014 was when the deep learning
community really kind of um i don't know
in some sense you know vindicated
itself in the nlp community so there's a
sequence the sequence learning paper
from google in 2014
where
they
did machine translation
and the way they did machine translation
was by
taking a sentence and running a lstm um
some if you don't uh know what it is
it's fine it's just some
black box that embeds um the sentence
into a single vector and then using that
vector it spits out a new a new sentence
so if you look watch the module on
differential pro programming it'll give
you a better idea of what i'm talking
about
um so this was really cramming the
meaning of a sentence into a vector like
literally
and you know at that time the results
were you know
kind of okay but it was
enough of a proof of concept and you
know surprising enough that it later
extensions of this really transform into
actually usable
you know technology
so it's interesting if you look at the
progression from rule-based
you know machine translation where
there's no machine learning to
statistical machine translation where
they're still
um
you know probably
still data driven but
based on
um more or less kind of some sort of
structure of language to the neural
world where there's really even less
structure um
and things have kind of you know gotten
you know better
there's a
researcher called fred gelnak who's
famously quoted as saying you know every
time i fire a linguist my accuracy goes
up um i'm not sure he said it was exact
words but that's
at least
kind of an urban
legend
um
one other note i'll make is that no
machine translation seems to be
the task at least in nlp but maybe more
broadly that has really
pushed the limits of kind of you know
technologies and i think it was really
the driver that got you know c2c
technology kind of going
um so in 2016 google kind of
completely transformed their machine
translation system
and instead of having multiple
uh
systems one for every pair so you have
like n squared pairs you actually have
one system that can do translations
between any pair of languages which is
you know really kind of you know
mind-blowing at the time and still kind
of uh i think kind of impressive
um
i'll mention i think i mentioned some of
these things already but i think it's
worth highlighting that you know these
statistical methods do
have a lot of biases in them so if you
translate
uh these sentences you get genders
appearing which are correlated with
certain types of professions um this is
even more extreme so if you take a rare
language where there's not much data and
you pump in something that's
just
kind of garbage you get some really uh
some you know disturbing uh translations
coming out um this was a film a few
years ago so they might have fixed this
but nonetheless um
it turns out that you can cram a lot
into a vector but there's some really
weird stuff
in there
um so then maybe this is a good time to
pause if there's any you know questions
before the next wave of slides
there are some questions on slider
oh okay sure i guess i was looking at
started looking at zoom
chat
okay so questions
um
oh whoa okay there's
yes i'll cover gpg3 how about body
language so i think i mentioned that
gestures
are typically not studied in nlp but
um but they're definitely fair game for
you know communication and there's i
think
interesting uh
kind of subfield mnlp which has to do
with grounding and how people
use language in the world which it's
natural to consider gestures um
uh let's see
can we build a common electric language
with
precise meaning so all languages can
reference based on it so this was uh
this has been tried so people have uh
there was a language called laguan which
was developed
to remove all ambiguity you know from
language so it would be you know precise
and everyone would know what you mean um
personally i think it was a kind of a
little bit of a fool's errand because um
i think that ambiguity is exactly what
allows language to be so efficient
so the meaning of a
of
you know as
a sentence
um
is a function of not only the words but
also of the of the context so if the
context already makes some things kind
of obvious then um you don't
really need to say it
um so
and also it's just not language has you
have to take into account the ease of
acquisition
and it's much easier to
kind of almost by construction to learn
the languages that we've evolved to
learn um and something that's designed
is generally not
you know going to be super productive
so nlu is a combination of plausibility
and fluency
so what is i guess natural language
understanding is something i haven't
quite defined because i think there's no
accepted you know definition
of it you can think about it as
demonstrating a proficiency or a number
of
you know tasks such as question
answering or translation
um
or i guess if you think about generation
you have to think about plausibility and
fluency but also you know
um you know
truthfulness
why did you choose to do research in nlp
as opposed to other areas how would you
think about
sorry this icon on the way
what you wanted to
study um during the future
sorry slido i don't know why slido has
this icon that makes me hard to read
this
um so i guess how do i choose to do
research in nlp i guess this is a very
much
i guess a personal
thing um so i don't think my answer is
you know necessarily good for everyone
but i think um just the idea of
what you can do
with language
just seems so
kind of powerful to me um like i said
it's one of these things that is so kind
of uniquely human and also i think
it seems like a window to understanding
um you know kind of cognition
because it's a way to kind of it's a way
to do the i o from
out in and out of brains i suppose
um is there research on how to
incorporate real time changes in
language like constant emergence of new
words and you know phrases
uh yeah so there is a lot of
interesting work uh studying um language
change over time um you know there's
historical linguistics which talks about
you know bigger scale changes of you
know latin to spanish and french and so
on uh but there's also uh interesting
opportunity to do it on the web because
internet language changes you know very
uh very quickly there's always new words
that come up and also on you know i
guess on twitter things are geo you can
geo tag things so that you can actually
witness the kind of how language you
know spreads
over time
so yeah there is an active area of
thinking about um you know language uh
change um
not just new words but also the
new words changing in meaning like the
word awful uh used to mean to kind of uh
sorry the word awesome i think used to
mean something more like awful uh but
now it means it changed kind of flipped
in sentiment from you know negative two
a positive
um
cool so
maybe i will move on thanks for the
questions
okay so um up until this point so
2014
is when kind of deep learning really
started gaining momentum and from 2014
to 18 it was really kind of
neuralizing everything you have parsers
co-reference resolution systems named
entity recognition systems
everything kind of under the sun
and you know numbers went up things did
get better because the models were just
more powerful than what existed
previously
i think a big turning point came in 2018
so there's this paper called uh deep
contextualized word embeddings maybe
more better known as elmo
and the idea behind elmo can be
summarized as follows so imagine you're
trying to do question answering so
you know our group we actually spent uh
quite a bit of work creating the squad
question answering data set with a
hundred thousand examples so it was a
lot of work to get that but um in some
sense a thousand a hundred thousand is
really really small compared to the
massive amounts of text
on the web
and so you the idea behind pre-training
is that you train a language model to
predict the next word given the previous
context
and so there should this is called i
guess self-supervision you just make up
a task which is called predict the next
word given previous words and then you
learn embeddings
and then you use those embeddings uh to
drive some downstream tasks where you
have
much fewer labeled examples
and the result was that across the board
all across a number of different
benchmarks
the accuracies
went up
by a few points so i guess it's maybe
hard to really appreciate what like
three points means but you know it was
think about these
systems were already hard to improve and
one point gain was very good and this is
like you know substantial gain across a
wide variety of tasks
so this got a lot of nlp people really
excited
later that year
albert
came out from
from google and
again across the which is i'm not going
to go into the details actually if you
watch the differentiable
programming lecture i do
explain uh a bit more about what you
know bird is doing um
but
think about it again as a it's a mass
language model which is kind of like
predict a word uh given its context
um and
this was
more or less just scaled up and you know
engineered properly and this again
yielded huge gains over you know
previous you know methods
um
so
so this really i think changed the
game in nlp from
having
you know kind of specific architectures
to do different tasks
to a world where you have one
architecture that does multiple paths so
i guess i didn't mention that bird is
now used to essentially power
all the or bert or plus friends
some muppet is used to power some
downstream nlp tasks like co-reference
resolution or semantic parsing and so on
so it's really kind of brings us one
step closer to having kind of a unified
representation back or unified one model
that can kind of roll them all in a
sense
um so going back to reading
comprehension one thing that
is remarkable is that
uh if you look at the
leaderboard and the accuracies um
they're way above you know human level
performance so these systems look like
they're getting uh superhuman you know
performance
but
one thing that uh we did a few years ago
was to really probe
into whether these systems actually
understood language um so here's a
paragraph and a sentence um
the number of new hugo huguenot colonist
declined after what year emperor
correctly answers 1700 which is right
here
but if you add a distracting sentence
which looks like it answers the question
but it doesn't then bert will get
distracted and answer the wrong thing
and quantitatively
all the systems just fall
by you know quite a bit when added when
added this with this distracting
sentence whereas humans obviously don't
get followed by that as much
so
it's you know one thing to kind of keep
in mind is that while um
models have gotten
you know impressive results on
benchmarks there's still these blind
spots that means that solving a
benchmark is not the same as solving the
actual underlying task which is can be
miscellaneous if you read headlines
where
computers can read better than humans
where that's just not true computers do
squad better than humans that is true
okay and what's what's a little bit more
maybe worries is that these models that
can be easy to break
um but we don't actually know how to you
know fix them except for by training
larger models and hoping that they break
less
okay any questions before i talk about
gpg 3 because that's going to be the
last topic
okay so um
is naming algorithms for cartoon
tv characters a thing or just a
coincidence for the two instances
um i would say
i would gather that it's very not a
coincidence because um
uh because you also had ernie that came
out afterwards um and big bird and it's
just you know clearly people are going
along with a theme there's another cast
of characters uh bark and marge are
other um
i guess they're not muppets but they're
other uh from the simpsons and that's
who is another line that facebook has
been pursuing
um is there any work on going to improve
comprehension reading between the lines
understanding
um
it's actually interesting because uh
these models large models
are so contextual and leverage so much
kind of external world knowledge about
text that they're almost kind of reading
too much
between the lines um they're making
inferences and making assumptions
um which is what at least all these
biases and in the models because it's
not stated in the text they're just
learning from you know associations
okay let me move on uh so to get to
the
now the final thing so 2020 so may
open ai releases gpt3 um i'm skipping a
bunch of other models like gbt and gpt2
which is in the truth of time and this
was
essentially a big language mall i mean
big is an understatement it's a
ginormous language model trained on
common crawl which is our
best
kind of approximation of the internet uh
so to speak and has 175 billion
parameters um whereas bert had maybe
like 300 you know million parameters or
so so this is much much much larger
so the interesting
thing about gpe 3
is
this ability to do what they call in
context learning so traditionally if you
use bert what you would do
is you have a model you show an example
and then you perform an update and you
show another example and you perform an
update and so on and this is called fine
tuning a language model but gpe3 showed
that that was
actually not necessary to get some you
know interesting performance so you
could actually do zero shot training so
you could say translate english to
french and you
say cheese
and then you give the prompt and then it
will actually do something reasonable
or you give a few one example or a few
examples and notice that this is not
training data in a conventional
sense where you optimize a loss this is
actually the input into the language
model
so language model all it does is that
you give it a string and you ask it to
predict next string right so this is
encoding
a task actually in you know natural
language which is kind of a very
different way of thinking about um you
know learning
um let's see do i have enough time maybe
i'll
uh so open ai has this playground um let
me just show you a little bit so uh
there's many things you can do um
you can
so this is the prompt
um
and i'm gonna say how can i help you
today um you know can you tell me the
difference between
um
sarsa and q learning
i actually don't know whether this will
work okay so sure
um policy inspired by q learning
um
okay so
this doesn't really answer the question
but that was
nice but uh i didn't answer that
question
um
yeah so
uh how about something else who founded
microsoft
um
okay so this is also you know what lie
but so you can kind of see that
uh it generates fluent english but it
sometimes uh doesn't have the best
tendency to tell you know the truth um
this is another example so again this is
a prompt and
let me
go to
let me dig this up so this is kind of
from the
course
syllabus
um oops
so
so this is some complicated expression
and then this is again the what you feed
into gp3 and it says artificial
intelligence is the magic that makes
computer do things that are not they're
not supposed to do like talking their
cars interesting okay so it's
kind of um
well you can judge for yourself what to
make of this
um
anyway you can
if you have access you can burn quite a
bit of time playing with this um
another example i'll show is uh
you can train it on cs221 quizzes so you
train it on quiz one question and
answers and you see how well it does on
quiz 2.
um
so here are you know prompts uh in
so what is bold is given to the
algorithm so this should be familiar
from quiz one and then you ask it which
of the following are examples of
regression
um
and it answers
uh a c and d which is which is wrong but
then it offers an explanation of this
which is you know kind of starts off on
on target and then
um it kind of
examples of supervised regression house
price estimation which is actually
pretty good uh spam detection which
contradicts what it answered
and
you know this unsupervised regression i
don't know if it's a thing
so you can kind of get a sense that gpd3
is really good at
generating
text
which if you just if i didn't tell you
this was fake you'd probably read it and
you know
but
you have to actually look pretty closely
now to
know that uh you know something is up
okay there are actually so i'm trying to
give you a
maybe a more balanced view of gp3 i
think if you go on the internet and look
at all the twitter you'll just be
completely blown away by all the awesome
things people are building out there but
i want to kind of balance it out with
some things which are like yeah maybe
it's not doing everything but
um
several other things to mention
now that gender bias i think is very hot
on people's minds in nlp uh
there's
they have an entire section in the paper
that calls out that yes not surprisingly
gpg3 has gender bias
i mentioned before that there was
actually someone who used gpd3 to
generate a blog post and this ended up
you know number one on hacker news for a
while and there's even papers coming out
that says that gbd3 can primed with
extremist
context can generate more extremist
content which is again perhaps not
surprising given that this was trained
on the internet and the internet has
many things lovely things in it
um so some kind of things to think about
i think
so one clear question here is can we
make gpd3 more unbiased and lux less
toxic certainly out of the box this is
just kind of a
wild tool that's kind of
like you should not be using gpu
directly to generate things that
to show show people
um
another question is what what are the
societal impacts of you know using text
automatic generation
you know which is kind of related even
if it's not generally unbiased things um
but especially if it's generally
unbiased things um the obvious
worry is that
you know fake news is already a problem
and this is just a massive amplifier for
you know producing large amounts of
credible
uh sounding text which is just you know
swamps out anything else anything anyone
wants to say so that's
a potentially a pretty dangerous you
know world
um on the kind of more scientific side i
think there's still
the outstanding question of you know can
we achieve language understanding
without
a model of the world or without um you
know world experience so gpd3 is kind of
only trained on text
and furthermore it has no it's just a
large transformer model which has no
internal structure
and
you know one question is can it be said
to
you know understand language or does it
need you know the grounding experience
so
um
if there were more time i would actually
do a poll and get people to discuss this
because i think it's actually not
obvious what the answer is
um
maybe i'll uh
end with final remarks and then i'll
take questions so
one thing i want to just you know
starting at the top i want to highlight
that language is just incredibly rich
complex communication system you know
quote-unquote from x-ray cd glorif
glorious chaos
but yeah which is i think you know
fascinating to study
at the same time there's a lot of
regularity and structure
there has to be because i think
otherwise we wouldn't be able to
productively coordinate and use language
as systematically as we have been able
to um current models kind of you know
ignore it um
which is you know but it's also unclear
how to incorporate this information in a
way that kind of matters
um as you can see the field is moving at
an incredible pace right you know gb3
was on 2
20 20. um
bird was only two years ago c2c was you
know six years ago and only in the last
you know six years nlp has been
completely you know transformed i would
say even in the last two years it's been
completely transformed so
um it's interesting what will happen in
the next year and i think there's even
more i think urgency to kind of
understand what these models are doing
and make sure that the technology is
kind of directed in the right way
um and then of course there's a lot more
to be
said and learn from this there are
wonderful classes at stanford that you
can take 124 to 24
to learn more about
nlp so
with that um i will
take any questions
let's see
where is
okay is voice language a better source
than text language so this is kind of
spoken audio
uh it depends what you mean by better um
so
voice does contain prosodic cues which
contain more information than what's
just in the text
um unfortunately there's not that much
of it compared to all the texts that's
on the web
um
i think a lot of the issues of language
understanding
um can be somewhat factored out from you
know speech
often people convert speech spoken
language into written language and then
you take it from there although there's
definitely
infrastructure in uh
speech as well how do you feel
understanding multiple languages is a
plus of research
you know how do you feel understanding
of multiple languages is a plus
of research in nlp
uh so
a lot of
research in nlp is very
english centric which um
you know is you know i think a potential
problem if you think about fairness
right i think many
uh rare language and low resources
languages as they're called um don't
enjoy such high accuracies and those are
probably the people who kind of need it
you know the most so there is a
community of people in nlp who are very
much interested in how to design more
efficient learning algorithms that help
you know low resource languages
finally how has the study of nlp
helps linguistics grows as a field so
this is a really interesting question
unfortunately i won't have time to
really do its justice um
chris potts um is a linguist at stanford
has lots of you know insightful opinions
about this um linguistics is
interesting because
it was for much of its history it was so
so dominated by kind of formal you know
uh grammars and semantics starting you
know from chomsky in some ways that his
era led to this kind of whole feel being
dominated by a certain kind of way you
know of thinking and it's almost that
some of these other perspectives hasn't
really had a chance to you know to
breathe i think this is
in a lot of the still the this formal
semantics is still very
much um kind of in the logical tradition
where you know you have sentences which
are you look at carefully and you try to
intuit what might be going on it's a
very different approach than just
looking at
a broad corpus and trying to make you
know sense of you know what's there so
but this is
starting to change a bit i think at
least people are thinking about
how
these types of models that we're
developing in machinery could be useful
i think that
you know unfortunately
there's it's it's a hard
ask
um because
in some ways the
these deep learning models don't give
you more much more than existence proof
of certain types of data leading to
certain types of behavior
and it doesn't really give you necessary
insight into
um
you know language you know itself
because uh interpretability is kind of a
missing you know component but i think
this is a really great question and
interesting to ask like how
these models can actually help us
understand language better help us
understand language better not help you
know computer exhibit better language
understanding
um
can we alter
and add to the objective function of
modern models that makes them more
logical
and coherent
yeah so this is a
kind of a natural direction that a lot
of people are thinking about
um so why can't you have both you can
have
you know the richness of modern neural
models plus some logical and there's
been a bunch of work
that uh tries to fuse the two you know
together um
personally i feel like this is far from
you know being
solved by just kind of simple
combination because i think there's
something maybe
deeper about
um
you know how things should be kind of
structured
like you can add a regularizer that
makes burr to kind of be more consistent
for gpd3 that make these more consistent
but i think the problem is that why are
we using these models in the first place
is that they can't be captured by you
know logical regularities and the many
of the advantages that we're getting
from them
are
in places where logic kind of fails to
you know deliver so
in those areas i think we don't have
much
of an option we don't have the option of
like uh slapping on a logical regulizer
because otherwise we would have just
built a logical thing
um
how far is real-time spoken
communication in multiple languages uh
so this is like simultaneous translation
so if i am on skype and i speak in
english and it comes out in
uh
japanese or something um
this is actually i would say that this
is
i mean not mature technology by any
means right now but it's it's coming
and i think there's been work
uh first of all speech recognition i
think is you know getting really really
good then the other two main challenges
in in machine translation what makes
real time difficult is that you know
word order in languages differ so you
can't translate word to word so you have
to wait a little bit to get enough
context and then translate it um you
know and so forth
and but there are models on nlp that you
know try to do this
um and i think you can do a lot by kind
of doing you know predictive predicting
kind of essentially what you're you're
going to say
um
so
uh i think that
a lot of this can be done without even
you know deep deep understanding of you
know language um what i think we've
learned from translation is that you
know while translation is getting 90 of
the way with translation doesn't really
require any understanding of language
it's just kind of matching um kind of
symbols contextually i think getting the
remaining
bit and having translations that you can
actually you know trust and are nuanced
then proper i think is going to require
you know quite a bit more work
okay so is there okay another
question
um are there examples of building
languages with rrl
it making advantages communicate a multi
in a
agent environment
um
a multi-engine environment so there is a
bunch of work on what is called kind of
multi-agent communication where people
set up some sort of environment and let
a bunch of rl agents um
train a bunch of our agents to act in
this environment where one of the
actions is
talk
right so this is an interesting um
experiment where you can actually get
certain types of languages to kind of
evolve
from
this procedure
uh and
and language does help you play the game
or uh you know
solve the environment better but it's
rare that these languages just
automatically line up with our
notions of
natural languages
because often these worlds are too
kind of limited
for
kind of language
to be
for it to be necessary to take on that
kind of richness
um and also i think just that
there's no pressure that these have
you know their human language might not
is probably not optimal for
um you know for anything it's just what
we have and what we kind of happen to
evolve
so
but that's a good question
what are major problems society that
advancing nlp will solve versus what
problems they may create so there are a
bunch of places where nlp
can be
used for societal
uh you know good so the one thing that
it can do in principle is to allow a
broader set of people to
um especially with uh you know different
you know uh people who might not speak
english to be able to kind of tap into
you know english
english resources and breaking down the
kind of multilingual
barriers um it's also been useful for
um
doing kind of analysis on
studying how people talk so
dandrovsky and others have a project on
see analyzing how
language of police officers and stops
compares depending on whether they're
stopping you know a black person or a
white person and this could be and using
nlp techniques to try to study that
question so i think um one huge area is
language is
used in a kind of all in a social and
societal context
and uh
you know therefore
building tools that help us
manage and navigate that you know
societal can landscape can be really
interesting um problems it can cause
certainly you know fake generations um
biases and models if we start trusting
you know translations or our systems um
it could lead to
um you know kind of
amplification effects where you know
kind of the the haves and have-nots kind
of push farther you know apart
all right well i think we're out of time
so
thanks everyone for coming and listening
and have a good rest of the week
you